sonst freunde würde ich sagen wenn es
euch vielleicht trotzdem gefallen hat
lasst einfach eine bewertung dar
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft hero und nein
ich habe nicht vergessen
die face karmann zu stellen das ist
einfach ich ich habe die halt einfach
mal ausgelassen weil ich gerade echt
heftig fertig aus ihr warum erzähle ich
euch gleich klasse erst mal ganz kurz
die welt ein bisschen aufladen ich habe
wieder so ein paar pläne für die folge
heute aufgestellt ich hoffe dass
erstmals an weil ich habe ein bisschen
vorproduziert weil ich an köln in köln
ich war in hamburg und okuma hier wurden
schon richtig hier wird schon richtig
geil gebaut alter ist jetzt sagen wie
wahrscheinlich alle wieder den kontakt
zum blick schon vor einer woche gemacht
und alles mögliche geil alte denkmal
pfütze honig alter geil geil geil geil
ich weiß ja dass ich auch nice aus ob
das käfer oder ob das zombie war ich
habe keine ahnung wer das war
aber es sieht heftigkeit und wenn ich
jetzt mal einfach so ein stückchen nach
oben fliege mit aus dieser angucke
unsere stadt ist heftig alter die wird
heftig geil gemacht
freunde ich muss echt sagen ich bin
begeistert wenn ihr wenn ich jetzt eine
face kehrte würdet ihr sehen wie kohl
hat gerade eine träne aus meinem
arschloch halte das ist echt schön
hübsch gefällt mir ich schön das direkt
mit noch vermisst diese scheiß arena um
mein haus pasta ich gar nicht rein
ja hier werde ich ja demnächst hinziehen
da hat sich aber noch nichts verändert
jeder hat keiner was irgendwie daran
gemacht diese kiste muss ich irgendwie
weg packte seine sachen drin
ich muss den umzug eigentlich weiter
planen oder zumindest mit haus abbauen
und ich wollte auch eine sache eben
machen und dann kann ich auch eben kurz
über köln reden allerdings erst mal ich
wollte ihn kaum noch fortschritte machen
ich versuche den einfach nebenbei zu
kräften gehört wie ausgestorben ist
allerdings erst mal warum kommt das ja
alles überhaupt zu spät
das ist erstmal ganz einfach und zwar
ward gunpowder klosters ich kann
eigentlich networld gunpowder plot das
hab ich dann irgendwo irgendwie ich
hasse diese komische suchfunktion ist
alles da muss das wieder neu eingeben
und möbel und das c was bräuchte noch
die kritik an die zwei kleine orte wie
ali bhutto scheiße
dann hab ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht
puh scheiße ich hoffe aber ich kann das
einfach irgendwie aufladen und meinten
auch alle irgendwie das ist also ich
will wieder total verpeilt halten auch
alle dass in letzter zeit 8 ist eine
feier am pc ja wie gesagt wenn auch
einige gesagt dass das immer mal so ein
bisschen backt wenn ich irgendwie mit
der scale die mit rüstung auf ach da
muss ich als wasser einfüllen jahre
sorry leute ich bin ich versichert
gerade cool das geht sogar soweit okay
ich dann können wir das jetzt einfach
schuldig uns machen und zwar macht
erstmalig ganz gut was ein kölner ford
gemacht und zwar macht dieser kölner
fortune dass alle sachen xtc im umkreis
von fünf blöcken zu einem hin
teleportiert werden das heißt wenn ich
jemand baut die fallen eigentlich in der
lava komm zurück zu mir und so also
richtig nasse sachen oder auch
erfahrungen wenn die irgendwie auch
irgendwie weg ist oder so da wenn andere
nehmen wir kämpfen dann kriege ich die
erfahrung das heißt ich kann weit von
der mob falle weg stehen und so was
alles also richtig richtig richtig
richtig geile sachen manchmal vier
bräuchte davon und 4 auf ändern das ist
geil dass wir mittlerweile echt ganz gut
aufgestellt sind bestimmt sind andere
viel besser aufgestellt habe ich auch
nichts gegen sagen aber ich finde dafür
dass ich eigentlich immer so ein typ bin
der immer hinterher hängt sind wir noch
ganz gut dabei was condensed wie öl
content station for creating condensed
condensed splash muss es verzaubern
irgendwie doch ich muss jetzt braun oder
so hab ich jetzt mega comeback hofft es
sieht halt wirklich alle sachen an
condensed man das ist echt doof dass es
richtige tendenz bleschke serum splash
sehr und so wechselt so und wie kriege
ich dass nein das ist bei mir nicht
contents ach so wie du meinst ich
condensed eigentlich weil er warte
eigentlich ich hab ich noch ned in der
banken der gold nämlich auch ein
sicherheits zeit war ich habe ein ganz
gutes rezept nach runden wenn das nicht
geht dann bin ich aber dann war ich zu
denen auch ich habe ja einen condensed
ach ich pizza und alle haben wieder in
die kommentare geschrieben
auch luca du bist so doof du hast doch
so ein komma hd ich schwöre euch wenn
der krieg wird ich will keinen krieg
mehr kraft hat muss seine busse läuft
der avec nein ich will einfach noch
nicht krieg ich habe einfach das habe
ich schon oft gesagt hab keinen bock auf
krieg bis ich mich darauf vorbereitet
habe sonst wär das jacket wenn einfach
einer die andere stadt überläuft also
jetzt kann ich erst mal ganz kurz noch
mal darüber reden wie so geht das bei
mir jetzt eigentlich nicht ach so damit
muss ich das machen aber okay das kann
ich sogar inventar eben machen
deswegen muss ich die nehmen so
jetzt geht das auch komme ich hier
gerade um
wer doof wenn du mich willst ich
spazieren das wäre ich doch wenn er mich
gilt wie gut also warum kommen die
videos heute so so so komisch und zwar
ich war ja in ich versuche immer in die
webcam zu gucken weil ich denke dass die
ihnen wie anders oder so aber du sagst
immer wenn ich auf dem server wenn das
ich möchte heute möchte ich es
vielleicht komme
ich liebe dich doch ich war in hamburg
und musste vorbereiten und dann bin ich
gestern abend wieder gekommen ich
sprinte nicht mal bin ich schon mega
schnell mich gestern haben wieder
gekommen und war noch auf einer feier
und dann war ich heute um 6 uhr zu hause
und war dann bis 3 uhr glaube ich im
bett und dann fangen jetzt erst an
aufzunehmen um halb fünf deswegen tut
mir das ein bisschen leid dass da so ein
bisschen eventuell die zeiten
vernachlässigt worden
noch mitte
recht so ich höre ja auch da und das ist
damit jahren das habt ihr auch so rum
der pis hat bestimmt ein spiegel da
hinten zu der zu den bäumen gemacht
sowie den er das für mich bei statt gelb
gemacht hat
oder soll ich jetzt bekomme gehen und
den versuchen zu klatschen welche
wahrscheinlich ähnlich ihn kriegen meine
richtung nämlich kein bisschen
verzaubert combat joint meine rettung
einfach verdammt romano ich will dich
das komme kommt na gut
ich höre schon wieder flugzeuge stevia
okay das ist ich hoffe das ist ja der
fliegt den raum und zeigt die stadt so
gut jetzt mache ich den hier und so
einer folter und jetzt kann ich den so
aktivieren und jetzt werde ich alle
sachen einsammeln die um mich herum
liegen
das heißt macht so und es ist direkt bei
mir oder kann aber auch wieder ausmachen
da kann ich einfach wegschmeißen
das ist ganz klar
scheiße jetzt kommt komme jetzt kommt
komme jetzt kommt komme jetzt kommen
ich verstecke mich jetzt hier einfach
das kann auch nicht sein er soll mich
mal in ruhe lassen
ich hasse diese kriegssituation sozial
wir haben statt rote nicht mehr ok ich
hab' ich war das übrigens nicht mit dem
river das parkett ich habe ihm gesagt ja
ich weiß das erlaubte sich da aber das
sollte erlaubt sein er hat ihn ja
gespannt
und dann kommen sie alle zu mir runter
und hätten nicht so heftig öko liebler
der neue werbespot so mega scheiße ich
kann nichts für ich habe statt rot
nichts getan ich habe nie irgendjemand
angegriffen und irgendwie sonst nix habe
ich da gemacht
ja gut ist jetzt ein bisschen doof aber
naja jedenfalls tut mir leid dass die
videos jetzt bisschen komisch kommen ich
hoffe ihr könnt vertragen
der konter kommt heute abend auch noch
und zwar will ich jetzt dass ihr mal
jetzt in die kommentare
erfahrung schreibt mal bitte jetzt in
die kommentare
um diese erfahrungen
ich hab den flugstopp gehört hast meine
schritte paranoid ist das anders
bochum sid joachim sonntag eingestürzt
und die chance und nicht geladen und
deswegen gehen jetzt ins items from oder
vis-a-vis mittag vorstellen
die neue sachen drin ein paar gute war
ich bin ja konter kommt heute abend
schreibt mir jetzt mal bitte alle in die
kommentare ob der kontakt
ob ich da ging's behandeln soll ob ich
da meine tage so in hamburg so
zusammenfassen soll
und ich habe auch ein paar sachen in
hamburg aufgenommen fotos gemacht die z
ob ich das machen soll
oder soll ich die map ist übrigens aus
entschuldigung dass wir die ganze
auswahl
oder soll ich heiße mann ich will jetzt
nicht zur stadt wien komme da ist oder
soll ich irgendwie eure kommentare
beantworten bei mir wäre es lieber wenn
ihr schreibt hamburg weil ich hab jetzt
keine kommentare vorbereiteten dann dort
das wahrscheinlich noch länger aber als
werner weny irgendwie sowas irgendwie
druck und das jetzt als geile welche
jetzt an mache alle items direkt da
deshalb mega-star aus
ich muss gleich wieder beenden ich
wollte die folgen mich heute ein
bisschen kürzer machen damit das heute
noch alles passend hochkommt und da ich
eh schon lange zeit immer immer über
ziehe einfach immer deswegen muss ich
das mal irgendwann wieder ausgleichen
halbwegs ich will da gar nicht zurück
ich habe angst ist er welche sind ich
bin unserer stadt entwickelt sich ich
wollte eigentlich heute umziehen aber
wenn jetzt komme ist oder so nell dann
geht das ja schlecht dadurch mache
einfach mal ne kürze habe ich mich
gerade erschrocken alter er war ich hab
den ton aber auch wieder heftig laut
gestellt heute für euch wahrscheinlich
nicht wichtig lautstärke leiser gedreht
habe
das krad sondern defensive schweigen
hier
der crystal boss auch nicht heftig
verzaubert
und alle die jetzt die folgen die bei
jetzt die folgen wie bei ghom gesehen
lasst mich doch alle die jetzt die
vollkommene sehen denkt sich
wahrscheinlich
warum hast du denn sorgen zufolge waren
die ganzen seiner stadt ja aber keine
ahnung und zombie hat ja auch
hingeschrieben alter an ihre
zusammenfassung ich darf nichts machen
soll deswegen auch ein bisschen scheiße
man also wie gesagt wenn wenn ich wenn
ich dann mal irgendwann die heftig
ausgerüstet was ich möchte noch eine
rüstung bisschen mehr verzaubern und das
war es eigentlich schon dann dann werde
ich dann auch ein krieg gehen aber so
zurzeit so nackt wie ich bin das nicht
sogar
na gut ich würde am liebsten meinem haus
beenden aber ich weiß echt nicht das ist
doch echt einfach noch ein bisschen
restalkohol war nach seiner verpackten
bauern partie gut freundlich wird
einfach sagen das war es jetzt tut mir
leid dass es jetzt so glück geändert ist
liegt nicht ankomme jetzt also jetzt
nicht dass irgend einmal mehr wegen der
konnte kaum kraft da nicht drin die
stadt schreibt ihm einfach fick dich von
conny ein spaß ist ja alles nur
spaß hier
ja gut ich würde sagen wir machen
einfach irgendwann nehmen wenigstens
tree mache kommt irgendwie drauf und
hielt mich das immer so wenn ihnen der
stream acht müssen einfach ich schreibe
meine konnte das nicht irgendwie ändern
können das weil sie nicht dass man halt
nicht so immer angreifbar ist
weil das ist dann schon ein bisschen
doof weil dann ich kann jetzt nichts
machen wenn wenn komme da irgendeiner
stadt kempten besitzt wahrscheinlich mal
im haus und snk irgendwie oder so und
jetzt guckt ihr vorbei und guckt da die
folge und der kommandeur war die ganze
seiner stadt sein egal müssen sich
vorbeigucken könnt ihr natürlich wenn
ihr wollt natürlich aber müsste jetzt
nicht nur weil ich das sage sonst
freunde würde ich sagen wenn es euch
vielleicht trotzdem gefallen hat lasst
einfach eine bewertung dar
das ist doch jetzt mega scheiße alter
jetzt werde er verfolgte mich einfach
ich heiße ja ich wollte schon beenden
und ich bin jetzt weg und ich sehe den
nicht von daher darf ich jetzt beenden
also ich hab mir ich bin ich habe gesagt
ich will keinen stress sie jetzt hätten
mich wieder alle nur weil ich dann
weggeflogen wenn man eine solche
situation ja gut freunde egal es werden
ehe wiederum hätten gibt allen daumen
runter nice geil geil schreibt ob ich
gleiche hamburg zusammenfassen soll oder
ob ich irgendwie weiß ich eure
kommentare oder wegen was einfallen
lassen soll oder ein paar videos aus
hamburg zeigen soll
könnt ihr einfach schreiben dann würde
ich sagen sie wir uns ja dann bald
wieder wenn ihr dann wieder einschaltet
oder im kontakt heute abend noch wenn
ich sage die nach hochzuladen